joining us here on the show is Andy
Samberg how are you Andy I'm good how
are you I'm doing great I'm doing great
so this is a great way I guess for you
to honor those who are actually riding
in the Tour de France that begins this
very weekend correct Andy would you
agree yeah yeah I mean that and I get
just honored John Hamm who apparently is
in everything Jon Hamm is in absolutely
everything
I would I would agree with you you can
ever die no I believe you just got up to
joined the Academy as well I read that
on the internet now oh he's can you
doing well job yeah John is and he's a
very handsome man - Andy not that you're
not I know right I just wanted to throw
that out there it's time comedy handsome
it's different so um you know the Tour
de pharmacy is a documentary of the 1982
if you will
Tour de France racing season what is the
genesis of yet of this whole documentary
that airs on HBO
Andy um well like you mentioned my buddy
Murray Miller and I who made the seven
days of health tennis one with John Cena
that pronunciation just like that we we
really love doing that with HBO and we
asked you know we could do more and they
said yes so we've started this thing
called legends of sport singular and
this is the next one of those we thought
why not do cycling there's tons of
spandex there's tons of cheating yes
there's tons of you know loud colors and
it's something that we could shoot so we
kind of jumped into it and we got a
really killer cast and it came out
really good for happy yeah the cast is
killer
I mean Orlando Bloom Kevin Bacon and
then and them and then there's some
interesting ones um you know you're
obviously a James Marston's in it then
the interesting what Dolph Lundgren yeah
and II don't really I don't really I
think cycling when I think Dolph
Lundgren but you did clearly right
yeah well the fun way that we sort of
constructed it is it takes place in 1982
but much like you know the 34 30s or the
a trio sports Docs work you're
revisiting something that happened in
the past and then you're also getting
talking head interviews with people
present day yes so we did different
actors for 82 and present day so John
Cena is a character in 82 and Dolph
Lundgren is John Cena's character
present-day that's like that and we're
do so where does Mike Tyson figure into
this whole thing then if you I don't
want to give away the whole story but
he's just a cycling expert okay I like
it great great and then see wet on yes
so they'll ever you got Chris Webber
involved in this thing too that's an
interesting one yes Chris he pops in
briefly yeah there's a little bit of a
run in it where there's there's all
these disqualifications to various
reasons and in this fictional take on
the tour and it gets whittled down to
only five riders and an ESPN announcer
says you know that he's stuffing them
the Fab five and that they will always
be known as the Fab five but obviously
that doesn't fit oh my gosh that is
fantastic Andy Samberg his Tour de
pharmacy premieres July 8th on HBO at
10:00 Eastern Time and then I couldn't
help but notice as many people did so I
guess it was easy for me I notice in the
trailer one of the trailers there is as
there usually is in these documentaries
that expose the underbelly of sports an
individual a source an anonymous source
whose voice is altered and usually has a
silhouette but instead this was somebody
was actually had their voice altered but
shot completely in the light and that
person you got for that out of pharmacy
is Lance Armstrong himself yeah how did
that happen Andy well we sat down or
right at you're like how do you make a
comedy about cycling you're not at least
try to get Lance Armstrong in it and my
butt
Marie wrote a really funny idea for it
and it was making us laugh and we were
like I don't know if he would do it but
you should certainly ask and we did and
he thought it was funny and we chatted
on the phone about it and she said yeah
let's do it
so we we flew out to Austin and hung out
with him and shot it and it turned out
really good okay
and then I know you're a method actor
Andy or at least I'm guessing so how how
many stages would you be able to compete
in in the actual Tour de France I would
say like holy low three stages okay I it
was not a fun it was well the thing is
I'm doing math because we're talking
kilometers here and I have no idea what
point oh oh three of a kilometer stage
would be so how many minutes you say to
put it minutes vibes like several
several minutes to two to five minutes
okay all right downhill I'm more like a
I'm like a burst guy I'm not really like
long-distance stamina guy so you okay
yeah downhill would help okay how do you
like to go at least seven minute okay
very good and so when it all comes down
to it though are you an actual fan of
cycling did you at all learn anything
about tennis or cycling through any of
the stuff that you've been doing through
all of us yes I'm well I'm admittedly a
much bigger tennis fan than I am a
cyclist and I'm aware of cycling and I
will watch you know like Sports Centre
coverage of cycling but I don't like
turn it on when it's on television or
anything like that I like riding on a
bike it's very pleasant okay
Breaking Away essentially that was at
the extent watching that movie back in
the day Andy does that is that basically
that's your experience that's the extent
of your of your cycling on a bike I was
in film school
I watched Bicycle Thief back out it does
it does a couple more minutes here with
with Andy Samberg work so I I do love
spring
you know I'm not like the hugest cycling
guy no I do know that you're a Niner fan
right from the last time we spoke
correct are you an awesome all right
Niners and Niners fan a fan and warriors
fan very happy about the Warriors well
city of Champions we're so you know the
Raiders might actually be a bandwagon
for you to jump on right now Andy before
they leave for Las Vegas I know they
were in Los Angeles when I was growing
up my dad was a big Raiders fan because
he was there when they were in Oakland
and I always pulled for them ii like i
like the SF Giants when the AA's aren't
doing it because they're sort of my
secondary team you know just be in bay
area but I mean I love Lynch coming back
to the Raiders that's exciting
hopefully cars feeling good I've got
nothing but love for the Raiders well
Marshawn would be great for whatever
next documentary you do I think for HBO
I think he'd be really a good yeah for
you to send out Andy you actually did a
cameo on Brooklyn nine-nine last season
and he was funny and he couldn't believe
I was from the Bay Area he thought I was
lying what do you think you're lying
about that I'm not sure I was like I'm
from Berkeley like nah no but then you
like me more when you believe me okay
which is how things work well on cam
stuff I am looking forward to seeing
this this documentary Tour de pharmacy
and phylicia rashad is infamous to Jeff
Goldblum I mean you really you really
went all out here this is fun I'm
looking forward to it thank you
you got it go boom plays the older
version thing he does now yeah that's
cool that's cool Andy that's that's
something that I'm sure that you want
yeah and so before I let you go where's
John Hammond this how come he didn't
make it
Andy Keith oh he's doing the voice-over
he's an area he is again he's doing it
again
yeah I thought yeah the voice of legends
of sport unbelievable next time come on
in studio Andy I'd love to chat with you
in person
I'd love that too and send my best to
ham you got it I will do that ham will
be joining us in about 18 minutes time
there's Andy Sandberg the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy